-I'm here with the one and only
NFL quarterback Russell Wilson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Russell, we were just
talking about
the Russell Wilson
Passing Academy.
I thought we could play
through a special
"Tonight Show" passing drill.
Are you up for this?
-Let's do it. Why not?
-Here's how it works.
I'm going to toss some objects
in the air, and you're going
to try to hit them
with a football
before they hit the ground.
-Sounds easy.
-Is that good? Yeah.
Remember, safety is sexy.
So, let's put on our glasses.
-Yes, for sure.
[ Cheers ]
-Here we go.
-So, you're just
throwing them up, huh?
-I'll just throw them
up in the air and you try to
hit one, if you can.
-Okay, all right.
-So, how many throws
do I get?
-You can get as many
as you like.
Here we go.
-Ooh. Close.
[ Laughter ]
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Got one!
Ooh.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪♪♪
-There we go.
-You got some more?
-I think I'm almost good
with that one,
but, all right, here we go.
[ Cheers ]
That was just a warm-up!
That was just a warm-up.
Let's make things a little
more interesting.
I have a cart of random objects
right here.
-Uh-oh.
-Let's see how many of
these you can hit.
Oh, nope!
Here we go.
Watch it.
See how many you can
hit right here.
Here we go.
-You're throwing those up,
too?
-We have a LEGO house.
We have a pizza.
We have a bunch of bouncy balls.
Jell-O.
-They want the Jell-O.
Yeah.
-Ooh.
[ Audience shouting
indistinctly ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Groaning ]
-All right, you've got
to hit one -- oh, cake?
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
♪♪♪♪
-I mean, it's St. Paddy's Day.
Shamrock shake?
-That ball's no good.
-You come out.
Wait, wait, hold it,
before we do this one.
Come out.
I know you're a big fan of --
-Oh, man.
-Would you like to --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Be careful. It's wet.
It's wet. Be careful.
Right here.
Now look.
I don't want you --
I don't want you to throw this.
-No, no, I'm not.
-I just want you to
walk out and hold it.
-Seriously?
-I mean, he's a professional.
He's Russell Wilson.
-Yeah, look.
Right here, so it goes that way.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪♪♪
-We trusted him.
We're on the trust!
The trust factor!
Amazing!
Russell Wilson, everybody!
[ Cheers ]
For more information on the
Russell Wilson Passing Academy,
visit thepassacademy.com!